let's talk about the air in China which
you guys probably have seen a lot about
we've done a couple stories on it
residents of shangzhou which is the
pollution wracked capital of China's and
nan province well last Saturday they got
a treat they were provided with bright
blue bags of fresh air
yeah this sounds made-up or from a
comedy movie but not the case let's take
a look
so yeah they got to go up into a nearby
mountain where the air originated it's
about 120 miles away from the city that
they live in and they got to suck down
some air for a while pretty good and
what you can see on the right there this
is actual canned air that is a can of
air that they're selling they're
actually selling that in China and what
did that remind me of well as president
of Planet spaceball I can assure both
you and your viewers that there's
absolutely no air shortage whatsoever
yes of course I've heard the same rumor
myself yes thanks for calling and not
reversing the charges yeah
present oh yeah that Mel Brooks
predicting the future in Spaceballs I
can't believe you may have Spaceballs
reference even before the show for your
movie probably multi yeah alright so
we'll do a little jokey and then this is
actually pretty serious is this crazy
like is this actually nuts that there
are parts of this planet right now where
they are living in so much smog you know
we've seen pictures where it looks like
fog but it's actually smog it is pure
pollution that they have to go to
mountain 120 miles away to get air yeah
I guess I wasn't giving you the funny
part first no the best line it says the
china's providence received a treat on a
tree yeah
like mine it really has changed my
perspective on treats you know I'm
always like ah let's give a dude's good
did del calcio it'll be a tree and
they're like we just got some air
yeah you like your electric cigarette
but you know did you know it's so
frightening it's so frightening that was
like hey we've got a special thing for
our citizens err have kids you tell kids
like you gotta eat it there's people
starving in Africa how does like you
better breathe yeah it's it's
frightening but the can was kind of cool
it was in the cab would look so pleasant
and yeah it would look like like but
doesn't a can seem like a bad way to get
pollution it's like an aerosol okay I'm
just waiting here they should do an
e-cigarette err err cigarette yes when
you get nicotine and air so it's good
and bad
we have to find the Asian Jenny McCarthy
yeah so said if you don't know what
we're talking about right now we're
gonna hand it eight to the story before
this but cigarettes and air it's all
coming in one yeah and one big thing is
this what can we do because you know
obviously this has something to do with
the amount of pollution that's going up
into products from China is that is that
really so much should we or do we all
with iPhones you have an iPhone yes but
mine
so we all have manuals maybe you just
have not in a box we don't even touch it
I just you know I like I like I want to
keep the Chinese employed okay but
nothing but really what do we do this
because they're going through their
Industrial Revolution now much like
India we've done it already so do we
have any right to tell them what to do
because look I mean this air eventually
is gonna get over here we know that the
water from Fukushima is coming to our
yeah the west coast of the United States
right now like we're all connected so
what do we do stop farting no more for
one of the cow parts that is not good
yeah cow farts are bad so they could
tell us that well yeah it's just it's
really disturbing that that China's go
to is not to like alright let's crack
down on the pollution let's let's really
you know figure out how we could do air
quality let's rein it in it's like that
ship these people on a bus to like a
higher area gears a little treat then
get back down there it looks like you
know what it looks it looks like when
the emergency landing system on an
airplane again let's throw the image
does look like that but can you imagine
I mean you know look it's easy we could
joke about it but I mean these poor
people had to actually leave their homes
and travel 120 miles into a mountain for
air I mean this is happening on planet
Earth is this just like proof of every
science fiction movie ever I mean every
week we do a story that I feel like
science fiction is actually coming true
right like we are destroying our earth
yeah and you know we're gonna have to
move to Mars pretty soon yeah I mean
I've never I was never one for investing
in any type of space travel honestly I
feel like I'm the only one that gets
adamantly opposed to like anything NASA
does except for their dead space well
you don't like tank I just was like it's
human what Sarah's most come on that's
crazy to me that we spend like 1 billion
dollars on like what's on the moon and
no one has textbooks like I it makes me
insane but then you hear these stories
and you're like oh well we got to get
out of this planet at some point so yeah
do we have to leave the planet at some
point yes yes we do we do we give you
get Eric a can of air and you just
it actually you go and it just takes